in no way home matt murdock aka
daredevil says that he's able to get him
to drop the murder charges on peter
parker because he's a really good lawyer
but uh is he is he really one word
answer no in his netflix series he
openly misses the opening statements for
a murder case because he was busy palin
around with elektra oh yeah and most of
his clients wind up dead before their
cases hit the courtroom and all of this
is without even mentioning the fact that
his uh nighttime activities would
definitely get him disbarred so let me
ask this again was it plot armor that
got peter out of those murder charges so
easily surprisingly no there's a reason
the murder charges against peter parker
were dropped so quickly and it's not
what you might expect and it's certainly
not because of matt murdock sorry buddy
hello internet welcome to film theory
the show that could be talking about the
multiversal future as spider-man but is
instead choosing to talk about the
legally fraught past of spider-man it
goes without saying but no way home was
great finally the mcu's peter parker is
forced to confront the reality that
there are just some problems he can't
outrun let's be honest out of all this
spider-man that we've seen hit the
silver screen thus far tom holland's
version of peter parker has definitely
lived the most charmed life he lives in
a huge gorgeous new york apartment with
his young healthy aunt and he had a
literal billionaire acting as a
surrogate father he doesn't even get
bullied by jocks the version of flash
thompson that he had to deal with was a
fellow nerd from the academic decathlon
team when i say penis you say parker
penis
oh no i'm getting harassed by a thin guy
in a blazer who's two inches shorter
than me and that's why it's so
refreshing at the end of no way home to
see him having to struggle a little bit
in a pristine new york studio apartment
that's apparently two buildings away
from rockefeller center which if you
look at real estate pricing is probably
costing him about four thousand dollars
a month yep really um really down on
your luck there spider-man peter in
general gets off pretty darn easily and
nothing exemplifies this more than the
beginning of the movie right out of the
gate we're hit with this huge hubbub
around peter parker not only getting out
of the spider-man but also getting
arrested by the u.s department of damage
control for the murder of mysterio in
less than a minute the interrogator gets
ned to confess in his hidden ant made
with child endangerment charges it is
electric finally there's going to be
some consequences here and no amount of
web slinging is going to be able to get
you out of this one i half expected that
we'd be spending the first half of this
movie in the courtroom and then it all
vanishes what was a very public and very
serious accusation of terrorism and
murder by quentin beck who it's worth
remembering was a beloved superhero in
the eyes of the public just gets
dismissed less than 10 minutes into the
movie matt murdock aka daredevil just
strolls into the room and says i don't
believe the charges are gonna stick and
then they don't in one line the entire
movie pivots next thing you know peter's
biggest issue is not getting into mit
oh
peter parker your life is so hard not
only did he beat the rap but it seems as
if none of them had to go to court but
how there was a videotaped accusation
there were confessions there was
physical evidence to make all of that go
away seems like quite the tall order
even if you do have the world's greatest
lawyer at your side so that's what i'm
gonna be talking about today what
happened what would the legal case
actually look like here what would the
consequences be could the world's
greatest lawyer actually beat these
charges so effortlessly or should the
third installment of the spider-man home
trilogy have been named spider-man home
arrest well what i think i found is that
peter unbeknownst to him appears to have
been caught in a bigger cover-up but to
understand how and why let's look
through the various charges that the
movie presents us with starting with
aunt may the lightest of the charges go
to aunt may the agent says to her quote
the boy was entrusted to you and as his
legal guardian essentially his mother
you not only allowed him to endanger
himself but you actually encouraged it
so would may actually face legal trouble
and if so what the consequences look
like well when it comes to the law the
first thing that we have to figure out
is what laws actually apply not all
places have the same laws and they all
tend to apply them differently so we
have to figure out who has jurisdiction
in this case in other words which entity
is the one with the right to prosecute
even though the end of far from home
took place in london may's alleged
crimes would have been primarily
happening in new york as such that means
we'll be looking into new york's penal
law 260.10
penal and after a quick pass through
this yeah things aren't looking too good
off the bat for ole may guardians could
face charges if they act in a way that's
going to cause injury to a child or
don't provide enough diligence over the
child to prevent them from endangering
themselves and peter parker faces more
than his fair share of danger throughout
the series spider-man is involved in no
less than two wars civil and infinity
this guy is going toe-to-toe with aliens
and giants mae would absolutely be
liable here provided she had known you
see the law only applies in situations
where the person knowingly acts in a way
that's going to put those they care for
in danger this means that may is
completely off the hook for the events
of civil war and homecoming where she is
in the dark for the entirety of both
movies as far as she knew it was all
part of a stark internship for infinity
war and endgame peter was definitely put
into danger but not because of the
actions of aunt may honestly the closest
she gets is in spider-man far from home
when we see her encouraging peter's
spider-man behavior by making him appear
at charity events and when she packs his
suit in his travel luggage it's her
giving consent to him being a vigilante
that said it would be surprising to see
any of this hold up in court she never
actively puts him into dangerous
situations hacking the suit could be
seen as an act of trying to keep peter
safe giving a speech at a fundraiser
it's probably the safest thing that
peter does in his capacity as spider-man
thank you miss parker for having me and
thank you you guys for having me safe as
long as you don't get physical pain from
cringing tony stark on the other hand
would have been totally guilty had those
charges been brought against him in
civil war we see him knowingly lie to
aunt may who else knows anybody nobody
not even your
unusually attractive aunt no he brings a
teenager without a passport to germany
you got a passport no no i don't i don't
even have a driver's ever been to
germany and he does all these things
with the intent to subdue captain
america the greatest soldier of all
history as well as his buddy bucky the
greatest assassin ever as well as a
witch that can juggle freaking cars any
way you slice it tony stark is guilty as
charged so now let's move on to ned
things aren't so rosy for him he was
directly involved in spider-man
shenanigans or at least as involved as
he can be while sitting in a chair and
he confessed to helping spider-man find
the vulture helping him hack his suit
and quote kind of helping him get into
space or as the dod agent puts it in
spider-man's illegal vigilantism you
were his main accomplice but hold on
here first off helping spider-man get to
space and helping spider-man hack his
own suit yeah that's that's not illegal
secondly when it comes to that alleged
criminal vigilantism that the agent's
talking about it's important to note
that being a vigilante in and of itself
is not illegal it's true that many of
the things involved with vigilantism
often involve breaking the law for
example breaking and entering criminal
hideouts or committing acts of violence
against suspected criminals but plenty
of states new york included have
citizens arrest laws that allow any
person to make arrests if they have
immediate knowledge of a crime or they
have reasonable and probable grounds of
suspicion that a felony is taking place
in peter's case he's not going out to
commit acts of unnecessary violence
against criminals in fact getting the
job done while hurting as few people as
possible is kind of his whole thing and
as far as we know the new york police
never put out a warrant for spider-man's
arrest even after knowing that he was
going around the neighborhood
apprehending criminals which strongly
suggests that none of what he was doing
would be considered criminal so while
the guy interrogating ned might be using
words that sound intimidating the truth
is that unless he has some other actual
charge that he's not talking about ned
probably isn't facing anything that
would actually result in criminal
penalties peter on the other hand though
does have a warrant out for his arrest
but what's interesting is that we see
him defending himself against a very
specific charge i didn't kill quentin
back that's worth calling out here
because if we look at what peter was
framed for in the previous film we'd
expect him to be facing much more
serious charges he has an army
weaponized drone star technology are you
sure you want to commence the drone
attack there will be significant
casualties do it execute them all stereo
not only framed peter parker for his own
murder but for the drone attack at tower
bridge while we don't see anyone killed
on screen we do see a bunch of people
fleeing from the drones as the queen's
guard battles them not to mention the
millions of dollars in damage that's
being done to tower bridge and all the
vehicles on it those are pretty serious
crimes to add to the rap sheet so is
this the conclusive proof that
spider-man was responsible for the
brutal murder of mysterious based on
evidence presented would spider-man need
to go to trial and once there would he
be found guilty well the answers to
those questions are no and no matt
murdock is probably right those charges
won't stick and you don't need to be a
really good lawyer with excellent
reflexes to make him go away either now
the crimes peter has to defend against
occurred in london so technically
british law enforcement would be in
charge but honestly we don't even need
to get that complicated to see how this
case is gonna go first and foremost it's
pretty clear that mysterio's video is
the only real piece of evidence here for
any and all charges there were no
witnesses on the bridge and as peter
rightly calls out in the movie he didn't
kill quentin beck the drones did the
drones were also the things causing
damage to tower bridge so it really
comes down to a question of who was in
control of the drones if the drones keep
an audio log well then peter's
immediately in the clear
but we're gonna assume that that's not
the case which means that the video is
really the only piece of evidence that
we have to go on here right off the bat
it's highly likely that the video will
get exposed as doctored forensic experts
are people responsible for identifying
analyzing and reconstructing any
evidence that's going to be used in a
trial and they come in all sorts of
different varieties everything from
crime scene analysis
to digital or computer forensics but
here we'd be looking for video forensics
experts something that a video forensics
expert might do for instance is look for
inconsistencies in the lighting or
shadows stuff that a normal viewer might
not see but suggests that the video's
been doctored this is something that's
actually becoming more and more
important in courtrooms as deep fake
videos become better and more prevalent
but with mysterio's video this one is
actually pretty easy to debunk they'd be
able to immediately tell based on
ambient noise that the audio had been
edited to pull edith and peter lines
from two separate moments in time
thereby getting the evidence and thus
the charges completely thrown out but
okay let's assume that they can't
immediately tell that the video's fake
is there still a case here well again no
look at the video peter's face isn't
seen on camera all we see are just some
spider legs that's not conclusive and
likely would not hold up in court all we
have to go off of is mysterio
identifying the individual attacking him
as being peter parker now this one is
actually interesting normally something
like this would be dismissed as hearsay
an out-of-court statement that's offered
to prove the truth of whatever it
asserts it's peter because the accuser
says it's peter that's not evidence
that's just an accusation but here
mysterio actually benefits from an
interesting loophole statements made by
someone who's dying are allowed to stay
in as evidence so his accusation of
peter would be kept but that doesn't
necessarily mean hearsay ends here to
get a video like this admitted into
evidence it needs to be authenticated
there needs to be a way to prove that it
is what it claims to be basically there
needs to be a witness to say yep this
one's mine i filmed it if there's no
witness present who can be
cross-examined about the evidence then
an attorney can argue that the substance
of the photo or video is hearsay thus
getting it dismissed and considering
that the only two people there on the
bridge were mysterio and peter the video
would never make it to court meaning
that all charges are dropped in short
for as unbelievable as it was to see the
charges go away that quickly and no way
home it's not actually that far-fetched
there was nothing truly holding up the
case not even the accusers and you see
this is the weird little conspiracy that
i think i found so this whole
investigation was put on not by the
police department or the fbi but rather
by the department of damage control
which let me just be clear is not a real
thing it's a fictional organization that
exists within the marvel universe
remember when spider-man homecoming
started with adrian toombs deciding to
become the vulture after his salvage
company got put out of business well the
reason that the vulture had to turn to a
life of crime was the joint venture
between stark industries and the federal
government the department of damage
control will oversee the collection and
storage of alien and other exotic
materials stark industry joint venture
with the government one that i might add
started as exotic waste removal but in
no way home allegedly does law
enforcement i don't know it sounds
awfully suspicious
and that i think is the key to what's
really going on here the way that damage
control comes after peter parker hard
only to completely drop the charges
doesn't make much sense if you're just
thinking of them as regular law
enforcement but it makes total sense
when you realize that they're not law
enforcement they're a cleanup crew from
stark industries doing this specifically
so peter mr tony stark 2.0 can get off
scot-free by stepping in themselves they
ensure that they're the ones in control
of the situation rather than leave
things up to traditional law enforcement
damage control is able to swoop in and
make a big to-do about throwing the book
at peter parker and his friends putting
on a show for the actual police they
make it look like they're playing
hardball while actually gently lobbing a
bunch of softballs the entire time
picking up a bunch of charges that sound
scary but actually amount to very little
all while waiting for the anti-peter
sentiments to die down in the process
they protect the reputations of everyone
involved oh yeah and it probably merits
mentioning but in the comics the
department of damage control was
actually started as a joint venture
between tony stark and wilson fisk yeah
that wilson fisk the kingpin who based
on hawkeye and matt murdock's appearance
here is definitely a part of the mcu not
really saying that it matters here just
pointing out that we should probably be
paying attention to who's really pulling
the strings the next time we see the dod
pop up but hey that's just a theory a
conspiracy theory about the marvel
cinematic universe meaning a film theory
and
cuts
[Music]
you